[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
will you feel like a failure if someone
doesn't try to kill you
that's a good question um are you
disappointed
all right imagine you ruffled all these
feathers and called out all these elites
for your whole career yeah and never
once did not trust
me you go dine at their establishments
you stay at their hotels you're asking
they want a guy like me to do it because
you're just crazy i'm not comedian
it's not real it's the best comedian i
was hoping you were gonna be like
because i can be bought that would be
yeah yeah yeah
they could shut you up i'm more like i'm
more sad don't try to buy me all right
what's your number to shut up what's
your number to bend over
and do everything that gas gavin newsom
tells you ooh it's big 250 yeah 150.
150 and the check is right there nice
150 million 150 cash to be [ __ ] by
gavin newsom on tv no you don't [ __ ] him
and he doesn't [ __ ] you but now we have
to arena no no no no no no no no no no
he would ban me your words i meant
metaphorically
i'm not taking it
he's a handsome man he is very good
and here's why
um
it's not ever about the money
that you're that you're giving
what's the best supporting actress in a
porn son i would that was my question as
well
what makes you support and not domain is
it who gets the nut
you know
[Music]
usually we like to share
[Music]
he's got to step his game up a little
bit if you don't know what baby birding
is i don't know what baby
[Music]
what is that thing that they do what is
it called when someone's a sleeper when
they wait for a long time before they
they act
you can take that shirt off if you want
out yo just go i could go for it
you guys want to see this woman's
beautiful body yeah
is
[Laughter]
do you call him bird christ
i wish i said for christ's sake
[Laughter]
would have been slow obviously don't
worry about this heading close it
because it's too distracting we're gonna
get there you just look at it yourself
and when we come back to you for that
information then you can talk okay
[ __ ] dumbass
[ __ ]
man fat [ __ ]
that's my that's my new [ __ ] i'm gonna
call him fat
we haven't done that yet
he never once commented on his voice i
know but now you're going to get
commented on you like a boy's husky
[ __ ] look like a mexican
toadstool
every time you walk in a room i hear
[Laughter]
[ __ ] from mario kart at the beginning of
everything
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
she's a fat mouth [ __ ] stupid
fat [ __ ] look
what's up bro
[ __ ] aquaman in the front row
darkness
handsome [ __ ] look at him
dude serving tables and dick afterwards
maybe i gotta stop [ __ ] all these
execs girls
but you didn't you cancelled on it no
you didn't cancel on her he don't meet
his soul mate hbo should love you in all
seriousness it's very easy not to have
sex with executive girls because they're
gay
no no but they are okay right like i
love independent andrew they're all i
love indie drew they're all gay or girls
oh i heard like every executive comedy
central got fired last week
[Laughter]
checking off the list
[Laughter]
do we have space back here in the water
bro
bro it's not enough you need space i
need a real estate for my [ __ ] yo
here's your grace tell us you're ready
i said i regret even doing it he goes
the first comic always says makes up
dude i need to listen that podcast just
so you guys can go back and forth like
one time i was catching a monkey with
a
foreign it's either that or you know or
i [ __ ] tell you the truth and then
it's just really sad
it's either it's either i sell the
tickets or i don't you know
because i call him from the adidas store
in portland which [ __ ] blows do not
go
and uh i'm like crazy what's going on is
everything okay like because i was
concerned i was a little bit concerned
sure and uh and then you're like yeah
you know i did that and jill had a hard
time everybody sucked brad williams
called me and said he [ __ ] killed and
i was like you know what buddy
i don't want to hear that you killed
right now what i should have done is
bowled you down into the audience
[Laughter]
i love you babe i'm just angry
you did not get me sober i did you kind
of did
by saying it i don't know yellow season
before that no no but no
you're just going to randomly make a
decision
don't [ __ ] me you're just going to
randomly make it yeah let's get real all
right you're going to randomly make a
decision to get sober
okay can i just say something to you who
does that dude who does it who does it
after a [ __ ] win you're on drugs now
do you know how you're on drugs now do
you know do you know don't become asian
and have italian
okay so what kind of porn do you guys
watch oh i'm always curious because
there's one just one just one and that
was one of my questions for you today
have you met rick from back room
rick from back room cast no i have not
yeah
you don't know where he is
i actually don't [ __ ] man i actually
don't know
background cassidy
for as long as i've known andrew he has
loved this this this man said this man
and his [ __ ] regular penis dude this
is rick's dick it is
it is a three-quarters pound spring it
is so average but he does product
placement i wish we got that pulling
spring money i wish
right write the check write the check
vane what oh no yeah i can draw his dick
i can draw the veins in his dick i need
to get you some more spanx material no
no i have it all i've seen and i went
through the internet
oh my god
there's porno
bro you got a nice little bulge out
dude you got a nice pecker man i have
the largest micro penis in north america
now women get blown away by it
it's like
it looks like a grub worm with air
muscle but
she
but you've seen like like like like
seriously like those little balloons
about the story you're really big yeah
that's me so you you're a grower
man women go they go this is a trick
dick
italy thing was so funny
why was it funny it's because like they
said that
the the symptoms of corona were like you
couldn't taste and smell
and italy was like the first country
there was like it's a pandemic like
everybody inside we can't eat we can't
taste pasta we gotta get a bottle
we can't smell great food exactly and
then people in sweden which has like
trash cuisine anyway and they're just
like yeah let it rip
give us a [ __ ] what do the english say
we're gonna take it on the chin this
week guilean maxwell the accomplice of
egg dick pedophile and suicide victim
jeffrey epstein was arrested and the
world finally found out how to pronounce
her stupid [ __ ] name i always thought
it was jizzling which doesn't sound like
a british socialite it sounds like
what's inside a rap groupie stomach
maxwell was accused of recruiting
grooming trafficking and abusing
cabinets full of underage girls not as a
producer of miramax but as epstein's
right hand in their child sex ring
congrats feminists female pedophile
kingpins are finally getting the
attention they deserve the patriarchy
has been crushed like epstein's windpipe
their human trafficking operation was
over 20 years older as epstein would say
this is the problem i have yeah
when the ig thoughts
can't accept their role in the ecosystem
you monetize the thottiness
i'm okay
if you embrace that right horrible
decisions embraces it it's beautiful
it's happy it's great
they own the word [ __ ]
correct i'm following these thoughts
that i thought were on the same page
okay i thought they were on this i
thought they understood you are
objectifying yourself and i will
objectify you in return as you wish
right i see a post today from one of
them
the post says stop this is some quote
[ __ ] you know they love leave them
quotes
they love these quotes it goes stop
sexualizing the naked female
wait for it stop sexualizing the naked
female the female body is art to me
showing off my body
is not about being sexy it's about being
and feeling beautiful there is so much
aesthetic with the female frame i'm
obsessed with that sometimes it's
abstract art and beauty i believe in
being confident in every form
the very next slide is swipe up for my
only fans you [ __ ] fraud
tell me
if i'm wrong
why can't she accept it it's like a fish
that's trying to walk on land everybody
says only fans is for sex workers it's a
safe space for sex workers and then when
somebody tries to go that's not a sex
worker they're like whoa what are you
doing you're [ __ ] up the space for
sex workers none of a [ __ ] is selling
nudes on only fans how she's not a sex
worker and i'm okay with you being a sex
worker i'm okay with you objectifying
yourself i'm open
not only am i okay with it i love it
i love to take part in that relationship
this is beautiful you're the flower i'm
the bee
i gotta pollinate you
isn't that what they do
i'm not gonna really do it of course not
you know what i mean but back in the day
gotta get some pollen in your nose [ __ ]
god bless you yes he did
some people getting corona out here
[Laughter]
so my point is i'm so upset with the
fraudulence so it's art it's first of
all let's talk about art
art is an object to be objectified oh
[ __ ]
you are funny what do art what do we do
with art we look at that [ __ ] and judge
it
and objectify it you are calling
yourself art you're calling yourself a
[ __ ] object
you're acting like art is better i don't
beat my dick to art
jackson pollock looked like he bit his
dick on his heart
that maybe that's your point it can get
like if it comes as an addiction in a
weird way i mean it's a [ __ ] addiction
yeah well men are addicted to [ __ ] yes
that's this will always be for the rest
of time it's a baby thing to do i'm not
a victim of this in any way but it's
super easy there are groups support
groups for you we need to go
just to [ __ ] [ __ ] on them
[Laughter]
german kids and original we were talking
about this because chris german now yeah
chris is german for the bit bro
this is character healing he said he's
okay with those good things everybody
says he's okay with this girl being gay
reality's a suggestion
he'll be whatever you want but the truth
is he's mostly german from a german
neighborhood
yeah he's mostly german and ridgewood is
a traditionally mostly german
neighborhood you believe this [ __ ] oh i
know it for a fact the italian sitcom
fails and he's gotta find a new identity
okay so now he's the german wild guy he
says the crazy [ __ ] this guy's genius
he's a [ __ ] he's
just keep it moving he's here for the
pleasure of everybody whatever you need
he will provide you with fun and good
whatever you need yeah i don't care when
i go home i [ __ ] unzip my skin it's
one and i just step out into something
you've never seen before but here's
here's the funny thing about germans
here's the funny thing about germans
if you can prove you have a passport
the journalists you are citizens the
[ __ ] germans hold on
to try to get your german point out
ten minutes to your point chrissy justin
i just steamrolled yourself with the
game
i approve of this method i approve this
you're getting two history hyenas
super quick add make sure you subscribe
to jokeworld if you're liking this video
so far and go follow us on instagram for
these free stickers we're also featuring
a new stand-up comedian on there every
single day 60 seconds so they're best
jokes so make sure you go follow us on
instagram if you love comedy i doubled
down i ordered another round and i heard
the japanese
no
i heard that japanese
honestly japanese that's italian the
weirdest language bro i'm telling you
it's listen of course you think that you
always think about that
right but it's it's more melodic
that's how you say grand hyatt
right
that's where you stay son i don't speak
no japanese yes i don't speak no
japanese but i heard little words you
basically just say
condiments condiments
honey mustard
you walk into the restaurant i don't
know what they're saying but they're
like honey mustard
yeah you just say condiments they just
screaming condiments they understand it
i don't know what's going on i might
start whacking off now thank you the
lights in the bathroom here are
automatic
so there's not a lot of movement
the bathroom assumes that there's nobody
using the bathroom
right so i open the door to the bathroom
and it's pitch black
i'm like there's probably no one in here
and then i hear
thank god
[Music]
was it you
no it's someone else who was it
you're in here [ __ ] i know
don't be embarrassed you were taking
this [ __ ]
and you didn't have your phone because
there was no phone like emanating
through the bathroom door
it was pitch black and someone just goes
thank god
let me try to stare at toilet paper and
pitch black to see if any doodles on it
for the last 30 minutes hoping someone's
gonna walk in this [ __ ] bathroom save
my life who was it
it's you
i'm not starting the show until we find
out who was doing that
i swear to god
[Applause]
who is taking this
[ __ ] and sat on that toilet and didn't
move
the thing registers your movement too
that means you were locked on that
toilet no cell phones just standing
straight at the door in front of you
who shits like this
who shits like this no cellphone
bro i'd rather have a cell phone than
toilet paper i can't [ __ ] without a cell
phone
bro if i go to the bathroom and take a
[ __ ] and i'll have my cell phone i will
waddle back out to wherever the [ __ ] i
came from
legs around my ankles because the most
important thing was not with me
and you are in this crowd right now some
psychopath went to take his [ __ ] without
a phone
i'm looking at you indians mother all
right i smelled a little tandoori back
there
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
there was a irish nobleman who saw that
the irish were starving to death yeah
and the british didn't care
so he wrote a modest proposal okay and
he said let's just start
having the irish cook their children
little piglets and sell them to the
british to eat okay
jonathan swift jonathan swift satire
yeah satire and so i said this is a
jonathan swift satire on my own show
and then i set all that on air and i
said this is satire so i said if we're
going to
have a lockdown that starves the third
world to death then we should be ready
to collapse here and eat our neighbors
because within about 10 to 15 days
depending on estimates most people
either commit suicide or become
cannibals so i said then within that
spectrum i'm ready to not watch my
children starve to death you left us
that want the lockdowns and wondered by
starving to death i will eat your ass it
was all a satire and i told them it was
satire in a 10-minute ramp they added it
down to two minutes got over 50 million
views and people my neighbors both moved
down on both sides
dude you know how i knew that i wasn't
taking it seriously
because like for the first
maybe two weeks
i washed my hands after i peed
and then after a while you're like
man i'm good bro
okay like we're sitting here playing
video games you're all here if i lose
you'll get to tag teaming me let's go
but you're gonna
[Music]
i did not mean it that way
i apologize tag me down
[Music]
to be honest
mark uh how long often do you have sex
well that's okay all right we're done
we got two twenty three brock yeah yeah
as a young buckaroo you should be having
sex tonight that's the thing that's
that's different is that you like you
come twice a week
you do yeah whereas like
so all sexual interactions probably like
three to four a week okay but then also
like you know oh deal stop it stop it
with your little [ __ ] [ __ ] get out of
here
it's just so stupid
well he was about to say he's like
sometimes i'll just go down on her or
nothing no oh that's what he was saying
excuse me what's wrong with that but get
nothing in return no why did you think
he was going to say that yeah well what
were you going to say
yeah oh jerk off yeah yeah what's even
crazier that is crazy how are you three
to four times
hold on you're a maniac dude that's
crazy out of college this is what he
would do that makes perfect sense nah
he's a nympho son
that's nipple
that's crazy
most days guys are jerking off once a
day i'm not saying it's right but that's
what they're doing no they're not dude i
was in college bro we all showered
together we jerk off every other day
together
we had a dorm room we would all shower
we all be talking ourselves in the
shower one dude would just drop out of
the conversation for no reason and we'd
be like
ow
what do you mean i like it when they
talk what if it's not intelligent what
they're still funny
they're just talking
they don't know that this is boring it's
fun it's always fun when they talk if
they talk and it's interesting it's
interesting they talk and it's dumb
they're like they don't know that you're
dumb
it's amazing it's always good when they
talk that's why we listen
and then that's why they talk because we
listen
this is the world
nah we just listen cause they're hot
that's what that's what i'm saying but
it's like
i'm not taking in or laughing because
i'm just not taking it in like it would
be the same as if i watched it on mute
ow you have done so much crazy [ __ ] to
get [ __ ] you have definitely laughed at
a hot girl get out of here
you wore big hats and [ __ ] dreads you
stopped crazy on a [ __ ] platform at a
club you wrote a manual
you read a manual to get
i was like you had a [ __ ] peacock
head and you're like use tiptoed yeah
you stood down
that's how is it
different he made himself taller this
way he made himself taller this way yeah
it is you push the ground down yeah this
is more ridiculous what's more
ridiculous the hat and the the book and
the lifestyle i don't understand why
that's ridiculous
you could get a manual from somewhere
you're gonna watch your puerto rican
brethren sexually harass women on the
street and learn that way fire yeah
that's how i learned initially and then
i learned a better way wear stupid
outfits and then the women harass you
yeah he's trying to think i'm doing
i'm telling both the paul brothers if
you don't get in the ring with me at the
same time you're with jeffrey epstein
and i'm going to steal your hat let me
see what you do slogan
oh
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
you're a virgin he's not sweetheart
you've been cheated on
[Applause]
oh before oh thank god i don't mean to
snitch on you bro but that was crazy
so you had sex already you haven't yo
this guy commends this guy right here
round of applause for this guy
kind of look because nah
you don't know how good dick is
he knows how good [ __ ] is
you don't know what you're missing
you're like a chinese person with
freedom
is there a dessert you like
what's your favorite dessert
publix cake
mark publix marble cake sweetheart you
are one sheltered beautiful little leg
what a beautiful sweet girl right here
publix marble cake is your favorite
dessert
come on atlanta ain't there something
that gives you a heart attack that you
could take this girl to go get she don't
want nothing that starts with a d
okay so imagine you had publix marble
cake which sounds like a punishment
but i'ma go with you but then
buttercream icing
on top at whatever temperature you
[Music]
you wanted had a meal that you've been
having that for your whole life right
and then all of a sudden you can't have
it anymore
bummer right
now imagine
every night you went to sleep next to it
not only did you go to sleep next to it
sometimes it would rub up against you
right and sometimes you're dreaming
you're like oh my god i wish i had some
butter cream cake i wish i had that
publix buttercream cake and all of a
sudden boom some hard buttercream cakes
it's just getting pushed up against you
right and then you just gotta say no no
no
and then instead of eating the
buttercream cake someone just mashes the
buttercream cake
by itself
until it's only cream left
i'm just saying this is what this man's
going that's how much he loves you
he loves you that much because he knows
what it's like vagina is amazing even
though that [ __ ] looks weird
you think penises look weird but there's
so many penis-like things like you have
this like bananas are penis-like
eggplants or penis like there's so many
penis-looking things there's not a lot
of vagina-looking things
you know so like you see [ __ ] for the
first time you're just like
whoa
that's crazy
what what
circles sweetheart do you even know what
a [ __ ] looks like
this girl just said circles look like
vaginas circles bruh
have you ever looked at like the olympic
logo and be like damn that's five
[ __ ] all stuck together like
[ __ ] circles
take this girl out the house more
circle [ __ ] ain't even circular
right it's more of like an oval kinda
yeah he knows you don't know
anyone in the industry who said she
hasn't been an escort she's [ __ ]
lying right i don't care about it like
at the end of the day sex for money
is like
we spoke about it
on the episode i'm like i'm sorry though
like it's truly great
dude there's a guy who's on uh rogan
today about uh the the ufo guy bob
lizzie yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're having dinner the night before and
he was like man i can't believe what you
guys do that's crazy i'm like
you talk to aliens yeah
you can't talk to seven people in an
audience and make a joke you're going to
rehab three months ago um
i started smoking weed again
and then i started drinking again
and then it became um a daily thing and
i started taking like
get to the point where i was taking two
thousand three thousand milligrams of
edibles a day
drinking at night
vomiting on the freeway
waking up to your own vomiting
hotels for life
um i could see i can feel
already my life falling apart just
because we're we're talking about
something serious right yeah
should you have been at my wedding
um
[Music]
should you have been in my wedding stop
for a second or was it the right thing
to happen
did i do the right thing did i do the
right thing manipulative
why couldn't i come ruin your wedding
that's what you're asking oh and so why
wasn't i invited to come ruin your
wedding my wife's day okay this is her
special can you this is her netflix
can you give me 40 seconds can you give
me 40 seconds yes to respond with you
not interrupting i don't like it so you
just did a step
so what you just did was you just called
me
pat morita
you think that i would
but he was an alcoholic you think that i
was going to come to your wedding and
[ __ ] [ __ ] up no dude can i say i'm one
of those quiet alcoholics yes right yeah
and i say positivities hmm i would i
would have walked by your wife and went
you seemed beautiful and tight tonight
yeah good that's good right
thank you thank you so much right and i
would go to the ladies and go buenos
dias
right you look beautiful
that's what i would do right you would
this out dude yeah when they throw the
rice i cook it
and that's the thing i'm not gonna give
it to you yeah yeah i'm not gonna laugh
i'm not gonna give me the laughing it's
funny you look funny
what i do i scoop it up
you're gonna treat me like every other
white guy huh
with that [ __ ] joke you're gonna
treat me like every other white guy oh
he's just cooked right so that's crazy
bro and this [ __ ] hit me because i'd
be looking at greta thundberg and i'm
like why the [ __ ]
are we listening to a [ __ ] kid about
anything right right it drove me crazy
and then i go
and i'd see the the gun kids from
florida from the school that got shot up
and i'd be like why are we listening to
kids about guns and legislation i'm like
holy [ __ ]
they're making kids make all the points
because you can't tell kids to shut the
[ __ ] up or you're an [ __ ]
if you're the adult telling a little
girl
to shut the [ __ ] up you don't know
anything about the polar ice caps you're
an [ __ ] so if you just get kids to
make all your points for you the right
just got to go well it's good the kids
are involved in the political process
well my favorite thing about greta is
they started off with climate change she
was talking about her future yeah how
dare you then she became a half tart
this guy right didn't she go half tart
she did she went hannah gatsby right
it's like she has autism is that what
you're saying someone told me she's half
[ __ ] i believe she has autism that's
the correct term what's the difference
um was she vaccinated do we vaccine did
you have too much vaccines
no there's no issues with the vaccines
right she it actually is a plus you know
doing the vaccines no no the the autism
it actually helps you focus on certain
things like what i don't know i mean
that's what they say about people on the
spectrum yeah let's ask spencer hero you
think he's on it oh autistic adam smith
that's what i call it dude let's go the
free market isn't like ask him about
anything you're like donuts well i'm the
best donuts would be in the free market
bro turn it off for a second dude just
[ __ ] turn it we get it you like
capitalism dude turn it the [ __ ] down
i'm sorry
yo five seconds to get up five
four
three
two
what would have been hilarious is if
they acknowledge jimmy kimmel doing
blackface and i'm not saying that we
gotta like hold him accountable for it
but that's the joke yeah
right isn't that the joke like talk
about the karl malone laugh at
themselves man i know that level they
just killed that's why we need joanne
rivers yeah um that's what we're doing
i don't want you to do it that's why we
need jokes
you think is promise promise promise but
in that in that funnies like you have a
perfect opportunity to call out your
black face and show that how you've
grown from it and show how yeah maybe
you thought was funny back then but you
realize you can't do that now and then
it's squashed it's done yeah you call
that out in that moment with anthony
anderson and you let him tear you a
[ __ ] part for it it's over nobody can
hold you accountable for that ever again
the fact that you don't in that moment
you're screaming black lives matter you
don't say it at all now all i'm going to
think about is you and [ __ ] black
face with your eye crooked
carl alone
well he do got a crook huh no i think
it's jack the guy with a crook i might
have mixed my blacks
come on my bad bro
lizard people dude oh [ __ ] you write
about it yo if you gotta back on this
trade
researching it right now is not stopped
i'm reading about these [ __ ] lizard
people they're lizard people they drink
baby blood and y'all judging baby blood
like that [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] delicious
probably yo
some of the actresses
actively manipulate that man and seduce
him so that they can get ahead oh yeah
that's real too yeah 100 percent
yeah what's real is that there were
willing participants
that that were they were if you're
benefiting from the system
why would you reject it now i'm not
making a statement about marco robbie
right i don't know what she's done in
her life and she probably earned every
single one of her roles perfectly no
question i don't even have to name any
names my point is you've never heard her
complain about hollywood because she's
getting all the roles the girls in
hollywood i hear complaining are 50.
[Laughter]
you don't think that's coincidental like
rose mcgowan
ages out of sucking dick to do the role
you son of a [ __ ] i'm just saying what
are you you're indian all right
it wasn't you though
i know it wasn't you
you look mexican as [ __ ] bro
you do look mexican
i believe you
because why would you lie
but just based on looking at you
that's what she thought too initially
there's a slight chance bro
she just found out you're not mexican
bro
did you watch that show indian
matchmaking
i love that show man
oh i love that [ __ ] show
what's her bio data you got some
you got some carfax on this one right
here dude
you don't know what that show is
you do know what that show is is this
your girlfriend or your friend just a
homie okay yeah there's some social
distance even within your
your table socially distances
so we call that zone there the friend
zone that's the
i don't know who's friend zone and who
you're a handsome dude
you know
probably got a good career ahead of you
if i had to roll the dice
i'd roll it on success
if i had to if i had to
if
if i had to be prejudiced if i had to be
racist
and judge you solely based on your
indian-ness
i think it's gonna work out
what are you studying
you're gonna be a teacher crapped out
again guys
no
a teacher
you sure you're not mexican bro
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] is going on
indian table
teacher
what type of american [ __ ] is this
he's supposed to be curing corona not
getting it from all them kids
god teacher
what type of teacher like teaching
computer [ __ ] or something
teaching history
indians
how we feel about this one right here
bio data score is low
right bio data score is very low
what would you give him on the ruby
scale
i really wish i found out who took that
[ __ ] man
i'm furious i won't know so you guys are
just friends who
here
did
it
did you really bro
[Applause]
wait a minute are you serving
do you work here
oh i didn't want to blow up your spot
man
handling all these people's chicken
tenders with your doodoo fingers
[Applause]
bro he was so excited to have a light
dude
he just ran out you didn't wash your
hands bro i didn't hear nothing
dude be honest what'd you say so you
know i'm not my life when i opened the
door what'd you say
[Music]
let there be light all right look man
it's an hour long video i'm gonna have
more than one plug in here plus i know
that you didn't go follow the instagram
or subscribe to this account so go do
that right now get these stickers dude
don't make me come back
i'll do a third ad
i will i was so excited to go to this
[ __ ] dinner i was geeked for you son
do you know i bought a suit
so keep in mind that keep in mind the
dinner is a thousand dollars me and my
shorty right i buy a suit five hundred
each a thousand each okay thousand
that's crazy
[Laughter]
wait till you hear about this dinner
like an angry kramer right now ready
here we go
thousand dollar dinner right pre-booked
we get it i'm so [ __ ] hyped yeah we
start looking up the right way to eat
the food how to operate in the gym okay
you gotta wear a suit okay boom i gotta
wear a suit i go buy a [ __ ] suit
right i bought i even have sizes for you
in japan yeah i bought it in america
okay i was prepared i brought the suit
over there right i brought a new pair of
shoes i bought the belt i bought the
shirt i spent a thousand dollars on the
suit the whole thing
i'm 2 000 deep
for jiro okay
we go to jira right we're running late
the [ __ ] is in the subway you can't even
find it you gotta go through some back
entrances like you're trying to get into
a nightclub in the 80s like some real
crazy [ __ ] we're running mad late shorty
got on heels and [ __ ]
she's like you're rushing too
we should go this
and i developed a cool way to tell her
to shut up without saying shut up i just
go pop up
no
but shut up is like aggressive but if
you pop up
they don't really know what to do it
just stops
they look bad
it's good
[Music]
i have to improvise we were about to be
late you can't be late that's the [ __ ]
my girl are doing you cannot be [ __ ]
late for a thousand dollar dinner
he's a japanese he doesn't have a
[ __ ] feeling
late in their whole life yeah okay these
are very principled formal people okay i
pull up in i pull up in i pull up and i
pull up in okay
we finally get there three minutes to
spare we sit down thank god we got it
okay would you like me to take your
jacket the girl at the door says i ain't
even get the show jiro
i didn't get to show him my blazer yet
you know what i mean but i reluctantly
give the double breasted so jira never
saw a double breaster i tried to sushi
that morning i prepared myself a sushi i
took a nap
i wasn't about to go to gero tire i took
a nap
i put on his suit
pressed i had that [ __ ] hanging for
three days
put it in the shower i put the shirt in
the shower to get the wrinkles yeah
i sit down
no jacket i sit down
i look up
i see
jiro
i'm like wow he looks great still
and then i realized oh [ __ ]
it was actually his son
that's a problem now the son was in the
documentary i'm like oh my he's aged
but this is still awesome that i at
least get the son because jira is 94
years old i was worried he wasn't even
going to be there so i was like boom we
got the sun from the documentary we're
good
i look to his left
and there's jira word jiro and his son i
got the double whammy
oh you're hype i'm [ __ ] hyped
can we get you something to drink green
tea
i know better
i looked at the rules don't order
alcohol as disrespect
i sit down
shorty sits down green tea green tea
right there
piping hot
piping hot well you're even more excited
i'm so excited but it was so hot oh gosh
i tried to drink i had to put it back
down let it cool off i had to let it
cool off it was so piping hot
it was piping bro
what was it like
sonic was piping right
we
we get the first piece of sushi right
i put it in my mouth
i take two bites
i almost threw up on jiro's son
i almost threw up on giro's son the
wasabi started to crawl down my nose
okay the wasabi is crawling down my nose
i'm trying to hold it in and then i
realize if i don't suck this back
i'm going to throw up all over jiro's
son so i go
[Music]
i suck all the horseradish or whatever
the wasabi made out of back up into my
nose i'm like okay maybe that's
expanding our palate he's just setting
the tone
right
i take another sip piping hot [ __ ]
green tea boiling high green tea point
it down
next piece of sushi comes right away
it's once you're in there you're [ __ ]
in there it's on conveyor belt
take it we don't use chopsticks we red
you use your fingers
second piece of sushi
more wasabi
when i tell you i almost left the
restaurant
to throw up i'm being a hundred percent
honest with you keep in mind i had fresh
sushi from the fish market this morning
no issue
this is something specific to jero
two pieces in almost threw up
take another sip of the green tea
boiling hot s
just
molten lava just my whole mouth is
burned my tongue is burned everything's
burnt but you know what i'm actually
grateful because now i can taste the
wasabi less that my whole mouth is burnt
right
a guy comes up he starts about to pour
more green tea into my cup
right
green tea
i go i go no no no thank you no thank
you
he looks at me
in front of my shorty
in front of jiro
in front of giro junior
he goes
oh it's a free
i just paid a thousand dollars
you think i can't afford whatever the
[ __ ] the cost of a little extra green
tea would be the left tends to have all
these sayings love conquers all love
will lead the way etcetera all right
lead would love them until they
disagree with me [ __ ] you your piece of
[ __ ] they're literally your girlfriend
that's all the left is right they're the
sweetest person in the entire world as
long as you agree with everything they
say
that's a cold-hearted [ __ ] right there
they are not playing around on peaceful
protests
let's light some [ __ ] on fire there will
be blood
i rolled the [ __ ] dice on that one
holy [ __ ]
how pregnant sweetheart
seven and a half months ah we're gonna
get a leg out of that thing tonight for
sure dude
one hard laugh a foot is popping out
guaranteed that's what i'm going for i'm
not happy unless i see digits
is that the pops behind you right there
ask what's up what are you bro you black
what
you mexican bro
how you how you grow full beard brown
mexicans can't do that [ __ ]
mexican full beard damn dude
you might as well just be muslim dog
just [ __ ] convert
just convert your face already converted
for you
second and beard here is proud of you
like adios buddy
islam is the way way
[Music]
islam is the way way
[Applause]
we're the only ones that get that bro
they ain't got mexicans out here man
nashville y'all need some mexicans all
these unfinished ass buildings bro
every [ __ ] building bro like
come on
[Music]
what's your name mexican with a beard
anthony how you say beard in spanish you
don't know because they don't have that
word [ __ ] because mexicans don't
have beards you know how to say mustache
be got that way
is that your guys first kid
you look like you're in good there's no
disrespect but you look like you're in
good shape you're i don't know how to
say this but like you're kind of hot
is that weird i can't sierra is that
weird to say
not like you know pregnant women can be
beautiful obviously they're beautiful
but like you know i'm saying i'm fine
with it
no this is fat candy no disrespect i
just i see why you left it in you know
cops don't get paid enough yeah teachers
don't get paid enough either though and
they're not killing their kids so i
don't know what they [ __ ] them they [ __ ]
them sometimes
and nobody goes we should just stop
school
right
hey
teachers are blowing these kids
this is [ __ ] crazy we grew up
together my his grand his dad
my dad and his grandpa were best friends
in the philippines i don't know what
they were doing in the 70s if they were
swapping partners but somehow i have a
family friend who looks exactly like me
and i had sex with him when i was 19
for a whole year and then only later to
find out through his grandma
she was like wait like
you know there could be a chance
all the while everyone's like you guys
looking like each other
and we're like yeah that's what happens
when people date they end up looking
like each other but we really do look
like each other
i really want to see and
i know
yeah
and can we look at it worst of all is
that like
there was something about him you know i
found him attractive you know they say
like you are like repulsed by your own
life
it was not a pheromone match i remember
feeling like i didn't like the way he
smelled i didn't like the way a lot of
things about him but like a third world
thing though i don't know wait
pheromones are a third one no the way he
smelled like was there like uh he was
born and raised
that's racist
everyone from the philippines stinks
he's [ __ ] us
to say that i don't know exactly how
you're being raised indoor plumbing it
depends where i want to explain why the
u.s women's national team sued u.s
soccer for sexist wage discrimination
now there are two reasons one
they are the most dominant force in
women's soccer history two
they're [ __ ] idiots now i'm not here
to bash women hope solo has done that
enough i just want to clarify what's
going on so here it is the u.s men's
team if you can even call them men has
an incentive based contract they only
get paid when they play and by play i
mean get their ship pushed in by the
third world the us women's team was
offered a similar incentive based
contract they turned it down the women
demanded guaranteed money instead then
they went out and pillaged more foreign
women than the vikings and won another
world cup so they did the math and
realized they would have made more money
if they had taken the original incentive
based contract so they sued to change
their contract and receive back pay for
all the games they've already played
obviously the judge thought this was
ridiculous and threw the case out
immediately now glasses of the grasses
chicks between the sticks [ __ ] of the
pitches you can't sue someone for giving
you the contract you asked for you also
can't call someone sexist for giving you
the contract
you ask for furthermore if you ask for a
sexist contract u.s soccer isn't
oppressing you
you're oppressing you now i understand
it's shocking that women would break an
agreement just because they're in the
position of benefit financially but
that's exactly what happened here and
you dare say men have commitment issues
now in all fairness for the first time
in the history of sports outside of
strippin women are more profitable than
the men pole dancing is a sport by the
way and i'm a huge supporter of women's
athletics let's go magic city times are
changing people step out of the past you
bigots women are more successful than
men at soccer men are more successful
than women at being women welcome to
2020 man i mean zim or zur or whatever
goofy [ __ ] you white kids made up
because you feel guilty about not having
any struggle in your life based on the
money the women bring in they should be
making far more than the men and i know
how to make it happen easily you pay the
men
what they're worth
nothing
zip zilch zero zur this is sports
socialism they do nothing and get paid
anyway it's un-american now some of you
might say that that's unfair and to that
i say [ __ ] you you kami prick the men's
soccer team is garbage and they should
be treated as such put them in a bag
light it on fire is that what we do at
trash the men didn't even make it in the
world cup we couldn't beat panama that's
not even a country that's a shortcut we
couldn't beat honduras we couldn't beat
costa rica we couldn't be mexico i mean
we have 40 million central american
immigrants in this country are they just
sending the ones that can't play soccer
hombres the statue of liberty is not
holding up a red card i mean all those
people not one chicharito when trump
said they're not sending their best
you gotta admit he was right and you
know what we should build a wall so we
only let in the ones with the athletics
to jump over it that's how you win some
headers now don't get me wrong migente i
appreciate the jobs you do thank you for
delivering my postmates but i need you
to deliver a world cup hector off this
field on to this one please
steal these jobs the men's soccer team
stinks they are the exception to
american exceptionalism we can put a man
on the moon but we can't put a ball and
a goal you know america's greatest
soccer achievement was beating colombia
in the 1994 world cup how'd we beat them
columbia scored on themselves yeah we
can't even score our own goals in 2010
we lost to ghana
ghana a country we give millions of
dollars in foreign aid every year we're
losing the teams we're feeding seriously
ghana if you beat us again i'll tell you
what's going to be ghana the rice yeah
you can kiss that delicious jolof
goodbye
to me it's clear the women's team makes
stars we know who they are mia ham alex
morgan ninja the men's team is [ __ ]
unrecognizable who's this guy i see that
guy on the street i assume he's doing
magic this dude that's the most boring
rapper of all time this guy right here
that's a make-a-wish adult let me guess
he's the star of a soccer movie called
bend it like leukemia now i'm not saying
the women's team is more skilled than
the men's team of course not and yes
they win mostly because half the world's
women are stuck under currents they're
also trying to hijack the women's rights
movement to gain public sympathy to get
them out of a dumb contract that they
asked for angelina jolie going all in on
brad pitt
[ __ ] bruh
you know what's weird is like
when celebrities get into beef i judge
their decisions within the beef based on
the characters they've played
so like
like i love brad pitt in all the movies
that i watch them in yeah right brad
pitt to me is the guy from motions 11 12
and 13. he would never abuse his kids he
loves his wife and he's an ideal husband
so and also a criminal though is [ __ ]
maleficent this is a lying ass [ __ ]
that's a good point she would lie
is she a weird-ass girl she would lie in
order to take advantage of this
situation she trying to get custody of
them kids brad pitt probably didn't even
want to buy them [ __ ] kids angelina
jolie collecting all the [ __ ]
infinity stones of children from around
the southeast asia and brad pitch is
going along with it being a good husband
all right see that's the difference i
see angelina jolie is laura croft oh
she's a hero and i see brad pitt is
tyler durden i'm like yo he beats people
this is why i don't like croft tomb
raider stealing treasure that's what she
did she went to cambodia stole a little
treasure yeah good [ __ ] loud it was
good she stole a little treasure how do
you know it's good how do you know they
wouldn't like it over there she's trying
to steal brad pitt's money for her
children yes she stole the children she
stole them
you don't know for a fact that these
people really want to give away the kid
they thought it was daycare then gone
that's what they thought oh the white
lady's gonna do daycare she's gonna
build a well and she's gonna do daycare
your child is gone when the cameras
ain't on ellen is
here are some of the uh things that the
accusations made against on tv writer
benjamin simon
replied to porter's tweet with she has a
sensitive nose so everyone must chew gum
from a bull outside her office before
talking to her and if she thinks you
smell that day you have to go home and
shower
reasonable that's fine okay i think what
happens is like she's the king or queen
or
[ __ ] bull dyke i don't know what you
call it right
the bull cracker the bull crap she's the
bull cracker right of her kingdom y'all
turned into conservative republicans
immediately after getting to america
like
y'all are refugees
immigrants
and the second you get that dry foot
just
the second that foot drive
you're like okay and the immigration
they say no he said no hey he said no
immigration hey it's too many people
it's too many people
how how hey we need a system we need law
we need law
where my foot dry my foot dry
i'm american now feel it feel it touch
it
touch it
okay i cannot play domino at the table
it's too many people coming i cannot
play domino
how do i play domino if everybody coming
i'm not like you i'm dry food you went
back that's different that's different
that's different
that's different i'm driving i will eat
your [ __ ] ass like corn on the cob
yeah i'm ready
[Music]
you